I'm Brittany Schmidt and I'm back to
answer the internet which celebrity
would you most want to see in a sex tape
Leonardo DiCaprio because I heard he
[__] with headphones on and I think
that would be ridiculous yeah I feel
like that's the one celebrity rumor
usually I'm like don't believe these
things are here on the internet I'm like
that one I think that one I believe yeah
headphones and doggy style only and then
yeah we go it's like yeah it probably
gives you a lift and it's like not even
a black car it's just like a [__]
City car would you rather be filthy rich
in 1900 or poor now
Filthy Rich anytime yes
I get like I feel like back then there's
like they weren't taking showers and no
running water some guys aren't taking
showers now I just was gonna go to the
Turks of the guy who didn't brush his
teeth the whole week I was there no yeah
yeah chain smoke cigarettes didn't brush
his teeth once
a [__] DJ he was like the most
disgusting yeah it's [__] bad and you
[__] him all week long of course
if you were taking hostage five years
ago what would surprise you most about
the world today
I think there's a very clear answer to
this
how easy it is to [__] sliding ideas I
think the only fans thing is the biggest
oh yeah only fans I'm gonna start an
only fans back to that's what we always
get back to all roads lead back to all
the fans I mean at what point do you
just say just give in to the fact that
you could make like 200 000 a month I
know that's where I'm at trust me I
talked to my therapist about it I talked
to my therapist about it we have a
deadline it's [__] January 1st if I'm
not making a shitload of money in
entertainment by then I'm showing my
butthole I mean all right I mean when
you when you have a I can understand not
everybody doing it but if you have the
opportunity to make that kind of money
yeah
I know how many times can you jerk off
to a chick before it gets weird
I don't know if you've ever used that
one that's like old school KFC radio to
blatantly be like hey guys what's up
it's me it's Rob from Connecticut I jerk
off this girl all the time is that weird
that is wild um well I don't always jerk
off to chicks sometimes I do but guys
there are guys from like college I still
jerk off too yeah my spank bank is like
it rolls there's like yeah there's like
four people that are good in bed on
planet Earth and every time I [__] one
of them I masturbates if you found out
that a guy was masturbating to you
if you found out if he was like every
single time would you be like that's
weird no like [__] yeah yeah mama still
got it
like if you see you don't have any hot
girls there are out there all you're
doing is thinking about me yeah God
bless would you rather wear winter
clothes in the summer or summer clothes
in the winter what a stupid [__]
question uh
okay I thought it was good enough to
make our our game but okay I don't like
that question why not I don't like the
winter I'm not gonna wear it but I'm
gonna wear summer clothes in the winter
I guess I guess somewhere close enough
it's a good [__] question summer
clothes of the winter because then my
nipples will always be hard people know
I'm ready to [__] you can turn any movie
into a porno with the same cast from the
movie which movie are you picking the
Departed
um it's a good choice you get a lot yeah
I want to see all those dicks
every dick it's 28 too old to date an 18
year old now no yes come on when I was
19 I was dating a 30 year old oh heavens
to Betsy oh you old man you have a
daughter probably also because I just
had some semblance of a [__] yo 18 is a
child
I was all around the block at 18. would
you rather a guy that I'm [__] either
come prematurely or never come at all
never come at all really oh yeah oh yeah
all right that's that's feminism I'll
ride your dick until I come and then
[__] you if you don't come I feel like
well okay I guess that you know how many
times we [__] and women don't come yeah
and guys are like oh
I feel like most girls so if a guy comes
quick you don't you know you're not like
oh it's uh flattering actually no I'm
like is this your first time having sex
and then if a guy's not coming you'll
just be like you're done dude rather
than because a lot of girls will answer
I'd rather it quick than like it starts
to hurt and it burns no no no no no no
if he's not coming I'm like let me just
get out of here yeah let me just go home
which girl is worse a girl who loves
sports and tries to fit in with the guys
or a girl who makes you watch shitty
reality TV I would say the more boring
to me is the reality TV because I get
why she wants to watch sports
but you know like the girls were kind of
like fake they're like I'm your [__]
bro yeah I'd rather a girl but I like
watching sports because I'm trying to
[__] you know I'm like
I'm looking to take you to a game and
I'm like let's go watch a game that
means I either used to [__] somebody on
the team or I'm about to [__] somebody
on the team
sports game
because I've watched so dude I was just
going through my closet the other day I
have this stack of tickets like this big
all the games that I went to of like all
the guys that I used to [__] I'm like
like Dexter yeah it's just like [__]
yeah who is the hottest celebrity you'd
have a chance with if they got to know
you how is the hottest celebrity you'd
me Drake obviously it's obviously
[__] Drake and I would get along you
know I love Drake is because I was at
the ESPYs in 2012 when he hosted and he
did that song side pieces do you
remember that it was the funniest
[__] thing ever I was like oh this
guy's hilarious let's get all the guys
are here with their [__] wives I'm in
the back as a side piece and I was like
Drake you are a man after my own heart
and since then it's been all eyes on
Drake so we just gotta get Drake to see
the DMS yeah I mean Drake [__] holler
back dog
[Laughter]
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out